écoutez à partir du moment où les deux
groupes qui forment la majorité
sénatoriale voit forme à même vote en
faveur du président sortant on peut
imaginer qu'il soit élu dès le premier
tour il y a eu des fois où les
centristes ont présenté un candidat je
crois que c'était madame l'État à
l'époque ne serait-ce que pour se
compter aussi voir combien ils étaient
dans l'hémicycle pourquoi est-ce que
vous l'avez pas fait cette année c'était
évident le pacte de la majorité de la
droite et du centre Sénat il devait
repartir pour trois ans
on a effectivement
un accord entre nous au sein de la
majorité sénatoriale et puis surtout
j'allais dire qu'il y a un accord aussi
moral avec le président qui prend en
compte toutes les sensibilités de sa
majorité avec lequel on travaille de
façon extrêmement étroite et donc il y
avait aucune raison de marquer une
différence qu'est-ce qu'il symbolise
j'ai arraché à vos yeux dans le paysage
politique actuel déjà on peut dire c'est
une forme de continuité qu'est-ce que
vous vous voyez avec cette réélection
d'abord l'affirmation de la place du
Sénat il il symbolise j'allais dire la
place du Sénat dans les institutions
Sénat qui a retrouvé un poids
supplémentaire par l'absence de majorité
à l'Assemblée nationale c'est le point
d'équilibre ici des institutions et
on a une responsabilité c'est de faire
en somme en pardon on a une
responsabilité c'est de faire en sorte
que les institutions fonctionnent et que
les textes qui passent ici au Sénat
puisse être examiné est sortir pour être
présenté à l'Assemblée le groupe LR
devrait perdre 10 sénateurs avec ce
renouvellement qu'a lieu le 24 septembre
on voit que les centrices vous devriez
garder le même nombre de sénateurs 57 si
je ne me trompe pas il y a des élus
Macron compatibles à droite qui vont
voilà intégrer le groupe de Monsieur
malloret est-ce que l'équilibre
politique du Sénat va changer avec le 24
septembre selon vous écoutez il y a un
rééquilibrage au sein de la majorité
mais j'allais dire il y a toujours une
majorité elle est stable elle est solide
et puis il y a une opposition
et donc à partir de là je pense que
les débats vont continuer comme ils
étaient auparavant c'est-à-dire de façon
extrêmement positive et je l'ai dit de
façon responsable parce que vis-à-vis de
l'Assemblée nationale on a aujourd'hui
une responsabilité supplémentaire la
majorité de la droite et du centre au
Sénat est-elle dans l'opposition
Emmanuel Macron au président de la
République je crois qu'il s'agit pas de
d'être en opposition avec qui que ce
soit il s'agit simplement d'examiner les
textes de les de faire en sorte qu'il
soit viable pour être présenté à
l'assemblée et j'allais dire ce qu'il
faut c'est surtout être utile au pays et
faire en sorte que les textes qui ne
soient présentés et bien soient modifiés
soit travailler et voter comme on l'a
fait pour les retraites un dernier mot
très court si vous me le permettez le
prochain projet de loi important qui
devrait arriver au Sénat c'est le projet
de loi immigration on voit que vous êtes
pas sur la même longueur d'onde avec vos
collègues LR vous vous parlez peut-être
de passer par du réglementaire sur
l'article 3 sur les titres de séjour
dans les métiers en tension eux ne
semblent pas vouloir de les mesures du
tout est-ce que va perdre un premier
sujet de discorde dans les prochaines
semaines entre la majorité et les camps
de la majorité sénatoriale non on a des
différences et chacun les assume le
texte est déjà passé en commission des
lois il y a plusieurs mois 95 % du texte
a été adopté avec des modifications il y
a un article un seul dont on a fait un
article fétiche l'article 3 sur la
régularisation dans les gens voilà dans
les métiers en tension c'est peu de
choses c'est peu de gens on va trouver
une solution qu'on avait déjà esquissé
en commission des lois je ne doute pas
que d'ici le mois de novembre on a
encore du temps on trouve ensemble la
solution
[Musique]